how's it going read my name what about
welcome back to somewhere in I had been
wanting to play this ever since I
started playing it I'm so glad I can
play it again I hope you both feel the
same way all right wake up what the heck
come on what a vice but I don't really
remember what the [ __ ] I was doing
that's always the problem
well I when I wait let's look at the
inventory what do we got what do we get
what do we get we had a red rose and it
seems too beautiful to be real this is
not that that's refill eternal blessing
like yay
I wasted what what okay let's come on
inventory ah don't really get with the
[ __ ] clothes today there was
something about a cutscene that I missed
but now it doesn't work any mind what
the hell hit books there's a scrap of
paper having fun yes
I shed there's got to be somewhere I can
place the [ __ ] rose where am I now
I'm walking way too much back Am I come
on man
there so no job I got Aaliyah's wait
what does it say that place blue like
[ __ ] dirt all right there we go there
we go let's try to help him hmm what is
this but pain is gone what yeah what
what what is now what is it now there's
nothing left for you to take I tell you
what wait dear me could you be someone
from the gallery
what so you are oh thank heavens
there's someone besides me
you see I you don't have any clothes I
think scattered a spy David Edward this
we same we was in Val
Chad Reed dyslectic no no have to say
even down the days of the Roses won't
appear on me when my love loses its
petals ah though it was a gunner there I
gave her getting in the back now first
things first
we better find a way out I think I'll go
mad if I stay this dreadful place Tula
ah I still have a nice young me my that
was a load of me my name is Gary Gary
Oakes M or Eve a lot of people say a lot
of different pronunciation I will say
I'm sorry can't very well leave a girl
to wander in today and you never know so
I'll go with you okay
now let's go in I was a bit started
really that was solid West anyway it's
me that's good guy and watch out for
such bizarre things ah [ __ ] okay
okay huh huh what a lousy place for this
thing step back a tad what you're AB and
hey oh my god you saw Stan but uh now we
can proceed
alright let's go yeah whatever
whoa you can't touch my ship you can
touch it
she's breathing Brian what about you
breathing room Seraphin okay
they really want to touch boobs save
stations a painting of coffee and cake
okay focus
I'm sorry all right what are we oh look
at that let's check that out first
don't spit on me
yeah flowers are nice give me that
they're flower and I'll let you through
don't give I'm begging you I just don't
want to have a snap don't get I want
this for my little bit yeah yeah all
right huh what's going on here
it's like a maze huh
let's check out all the rooms first yeah
what is that
girls is watch why are those eyes on the
floor
that's a good question
huh does this loan have a congestion
problem probably probably all right we
made it
ah [ __ ] it's the walking Power Rangers
suits
do you like mazes no I don't I [ __ ]
don't
alright okay now it's Nick ah alright
follows me [ __ ] what is this
the base is out of water ah [ __ ] why did
I all right
Oh Harriette yeah mm all right there's a
lot of trick there's a yeah not bad but
that doesn't help the ceiling being far
too low for comfort no other mansion
does yeah I know about that trick but it
never helps [ __ ] I wasn't looking okay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
what what did they say
shake directly south from their red
paint
nothing [ __ ] I got to go through all of
this nothing
come on don't you dare [ __ ] walk back
here pass Chaka maka stop I'm gonna die
am i I'm so [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] me let's check the other rooms
I said I can move them
ah man I'm trying pods all right I got
this
and then
[ __ ]
alright go I think this should not work
[ __ ] Walmart right groans feel the
brakes on my brain and child puzzles one
March I music at
we're gonna puzzles but suppose Abajo
one more hard something amateur my god
look I don't matter we can put that I
know exactly why we can put that yeah
disgusting stare back what are you doing
alright I applied I dress all well where
are you going it's staring to the wall
alright there's a slightly different
color oh my god what is this a red glass
wall alright fair enough
we should probably save before I do
something stupid I just gotta saw the
[ __ ] wait let me try this there's
some fun yay yeah ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I
ain't miss clay now hold on it are you
sure about that I wouldn't trust this
thing give him the red dress well it was
kind of obvious I just wanted to see it
if there was something to it okay we
need to solve this puzzle
directly south check directly south from
the red paint what the [ __ ] I am
it's not really that difficult of amazed
when you see the [ __ ] top of it but
oh oh my god yes oh yeah I did it I did
it
what happened well it's the sound
whether I do the copy the cake the
paintings
what happened painting of a girl
depending of a large eyes painting of a
snake switch it in well what
there's behind the big tree how about
the [ __ ] what did I do
what what changed I don't get it either
and what [ __ ] big tree there we go in
here
no we didn't all right
whine self a giant vine guys cut
diagonal what that doesn't look like
very comfortable setting
it looks awesome it looks like a bottle
melancholy
I don't know that way
yeah it's true puzzle
I assume this is fake my char hubsan you
got a pretty clever to come up with this
stuff
all right behind the tree no all right I
got a silver ring all right cool I'm a
genius let's give the ring to the woman
how do [ __ ] am I supposed to know this
ring finger there's a beautiful okay
can I take the ring now no I can't all
right what am I supposed to do so how
many thanks ha ha ha
ah [ __ ] um is there something there we
haven't sold yet
Oh maybe he wants supplies no do you
want the briquettes get briquette no I
gave it up a cat okay huh
genius Dana
oh my god no
thanks creepiest [ __ ] alright what's
going on
I gotta end this episode here but like a
baby Zvi subscribe comes red today and
I'll see you next episode
oh what a barn a stay awesome breath but
you [ __ ] mouth every way